-Our next guest
is an Oscar-nominated actress
you know from films
like "The Lost Daughter"
and "Wild Rose," as well
as the HBO series "Chernobyl."
She stars in "Women Talking,"
which is in select theaters now
and everywhere January 20th.
Let's take a look.
-Let's move on
to the cons of leading.
-We the women will decide
what happens in these meetings.
I'm not a two-bit failed farmer
who must teach.
You have been invited here.
You have been invited here
to listen to what we have to say
and write it down.
Nothing more. Just listen.
-Please welcome to the show
Jessie Buckley, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Jessie, I'm so happy
you're here. How are you?
-I'm great.
-I'm glad to hear it.
This is a wonderful film.
It's a very dark subject matter.
It's a true story
based on a Mennonite community
where this group of women
had to decide
after these acts
of sexual violence,
are we going to
stay in the community
or are we going to leave?
It's very specific, but
the story feels very universal.
Was that something you felt
you were all trying to do
when you were sitting
in that barn together?
-Yeah, I mean we all
wore socks and sandals
and had our legs really hairy
and kind of got into it.
But, you know, there's a lot of
things to be a bit angry about
at the moment as women.
You know, girls?
Yeah, so I guess there is --
And it was specific,
but I think the thing that Sarah
did so brilliantly about it
was to make it universal
and to make it
a universal conversation.
And, yeah, it was brilliant.
-You mentioned Sarah.
That's Sarah Polley,
the incredible director
of this film.
And I've read a lot
of interviews with her
and those of you in the cast.
And even though it was this dark
subject matter, it did seem --
and I was happy to read it --
that you all also had
a great deal of fun
making the movie,
which is the way it should be.
-[Laughing]
Oh, we had so much fun.
And actually, I was, like,
laughing at that clip of Ben.
Poor Ben Whishaw. I gave him
an awful time on this.
And we're, like
really good friends,
and he would be my Friday wife,
which basically meant
that he went and drank wine
with me every Friday.
Everybody needs a Friday wife.
I'm up to being somebody's
Friday wife this Friday
if anybody -- if anybody wants.
-I think there will be
a lot of takers.
-So we had lots of fun,
and, yeah, Rooney brought
a fart machine onto set.
-See, that's very -- Rooney Mara
is wonderful in this film.
And watching the film,
it's surprising to me
that she would ever have had
a fart machine on set.
-It's always the quiet ones.
[ Laughter ]
-That is true.
-Silent but violent.
-Absolutely.
-[ Laughs ]
-So it's filmed in a very rural
area in this beautiful barn.
You actually -- You just sort of
left London for the sort of --
the wilderness, I guess,
a rural area you bought.
-Oh, right, yeah. I didn't know
what you were going to say.
Yeah, I did.
-I'd make a terrible
Friday wife.
-I don't think so.
-You'd just sit drinking wine
being like,
"What is he talking about?"
-Yeah, I moved out of London,
and I moved
to a very, very old house
that has these mad witch
markings over the fireplace,
and it's falling down, and you
kind of, like, put it back up
with a bit of Pritt stick
or something.
Just stay, stay!
-Were they surprised
you wanted to buy it
when they sold it to you?
Because you're not describing
what sounds look a gem.
-It is a gem. It's amazing.
The people
that we bought it from,
he'd lived in the village
his whole life,
and he just fell in love
with this house,
and he put all his last pennies
towards buying this.
It would have been like
an old farmer house,
you know, people who worked
on the local farm, obviously.
[ Laughter ]
And he restored it exactly to
what it was like in the 1500s.
So all these amazing kind of --
All the walls
are the original paint,
like pig's blood and lime wash
and all the old floors.
And it's so cool.
It's so cool to be in a house
that's way older than you.
-Yeah, it is.
That sounds very -- You --
When you were growing up,
your father owned a guesthouse,
so this is a hotel of sorts,
like an inn?
-Yeah, like --
[ Laughs ]
"Argh! You..."
-You would sort of hold the
lantern and talk like a pirate?
-"Come in, come in!"
-Did you have --
This is in Ireland.
What were your -- Were your
guests other Irish people?
Were they Americans?
Who would come?
-We actually -- Because I lived
in a town called Killarney,
which is a really beautiful,
kind of, lake district,
lots of mountains, and
a lot of Americans would come.
And it was so exciting.
"The Americans are coming."
[ Laughs ]
And we'd, like --
We all had to help, you know,
because that was
the family business,
and we'd bring them out
breakfast.
And then if they were having
dinner in the evening,
we'd all do a little show
for them.
So there's these really
embarrassing pictures of me
furiously Irish dancing,
which I was crap at.
I was so bad at it.
I'm like way too, kind of,
all over the place
to keep my hands by my side.
But we had a good time, yeah.
-Do you think that
most Americans can't tell
when someone's crap
at Irish dancing?
Do you think that
you got away with it?
-I think we got away with it.
-Yeah.
I also heard
you were in a production
of "West Side Story" as a kid.
What --
Can you just talk us through --
What does an all-Irish
"West Side Story"...?
[ Laughter ]
Like, how did that --
Do you try to effect
an American accent,
or is it just
Irish Sharks and Irish Jets?
-Irish dance. Irish dancing.
The Jets are like --
The Jets are called Jesus.
[ Laughs ]
Well, I went to, like,
an all-girls kind of
Catholic school, so to divide
the girls from the girls,
one of them -- I played Tony
in "West Side Story."
So I was actually was wearing
a big red suit
pretty much similar to this.
And they would kind of
give us French plaits,
and for some reason, they
used to, like, draw red dots
in the kind of corner
of our eyes because they said
that the audience would think
we were cross-eyed out there
if we didn't have
these red dots.
-Wait. How would that work?
-I have no -- I don't know.
I don't know.
I felt like, wow, yeah, I must
put these red dots in the corner
of my eye if
I'm going to be an actress.
[ Laughs ]
-Now I'm worried. I've never
done that on this show.
Everybody at home must think
I'm cross-eyed.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Congratulations on the film.
It's really wonderful
and beautiful,
and it's so nice
having you here, Jessie.
-Aww. Thanks for having me.
-I'm a big fan.
Jessie Buckley, everybody.
"Women Talking"
is in select theaters now
and everywhere January 20th.
We'll be right back
with Stephen Markley.